our fundraiser who promised to run a
marathon every day of 2022 has crossed
the Finish Line Gary McKee from police
Moore in Cumbria has completed his 365th
marathon with donations to be shared
between MacMillan cancer support and
West Cumbria hospice at home joining me
now is the man himself the Marathon Man
himself Gary first of all
congratulations how are you feeling
a little bit cold for a fair look uh
the grand the last part of the day we
got a bit Wet Spray though but a
fantastic feeling to have completed the
challenge uh took both boxes with
regards to
the front rails inside of it raising a
million pound and
the marathon's off job done
so amazing when I was looking at some of
the facts here Gary it says you've gone
through 20 pairs of trainers you've run
more than 9 500 Miles by the time you
finish the finish line
tell us a bit about the endurance and
how you manage to keep this up
I think uh when you talk about the
endurance it's just for me it was just
running marathon every year 26 miles on
my terms so it's about getting out being
disciplined and just doing what you need
to do I would never think of
not turning up because of whatever
reason when people are going through a
cancer battle
whatever I'm going through somebody's
gone through worse
um that it was just a case of one foot
in front of the other he had a fantastic
team around me they've helped me
massively significantly
um the whole family have supported me
from day one and you need that level of
support from your family to do what
we've just done
um and you know I was always confident
that we all get there and today I just
showed that
just an amazing Feast isn't it because
you started on the 1st of January and
today here we are on the 31st of
December how are you feeling about the
money that you've raised for these two
Charities and how important it was for
you to complete this
yeah the money will help so many people
especially the money that hospice at
homeless company will get they're only a
small charity
but they do fantastic work and it's a
significant amount of money for for that
charity uh MacMillan Billiards the money
as well uh half a million split betrayed
uh sorry a million split between each
Charities or half a million each uh it's
a huge amount of money especially in
these times that will go unfair where
people are struggling but people have
got behind me and supported me and put
the throw money under the page and and
believed in me from there one there was
only up until yesterday and I said only
it was half a million pound on the page
so today you've just seen a massive
massive spike in a rise and
and there is still money to come in we
know that there's lots of people doing
all the things that will that'll help
and uh put the money on the page so it's
just a great feeling
and you've touched on it a bit there and
we've been seeing some pictures of the
support along the way how much has that
really helped you and the team
last time I ran a lawn was the 7th of
July so I've had people running with me
throughout from that date there's over
170 people around four marathons
different people I've been into lots of
schools and school children have done a
lot of fundraising
um we have people at the halfway point
every day a homemade cup of tea and cake
and runs like cake so I think that's why
a lot of them turned up to be honest but
um it's been the support has been
overwhelming we have boxers put out that
have water in and chocolate and fruit
and it's those little things that keep
you going there's often a quart on the
boxes and you look at the court and you
just you know we talk about what it
means to each person what the court is
and
just a fantastic feeling
look Gary it's clear you're one of the
good guys but what is it that you
thought you know you sat down and you
thought I'm going to do this because a
marathon and what is it 26.2 miles it's
it's not an easy feat is it and you've
just finished
um 365 of them
what sort of made you want to do this
what was it the key to getting you to do
this
I previously around 100 marathons and
last year around 110 marathons in 110
years and I've seen the fact that it had
on the community and how people support
it and got behind me I realized that
once I'd finished 110 I could have
continued so we sat down as a family
like we do every year and discussed how
we could help people and how we could
raise money for Charities and I decided
that I would
here's 365 as an opportunity to
365 days of fundraising and that's what
we've done and every single day I've ran
I've run in memory vests for people who
have passed away
um the community has supported doors
vests and I just always believed in
myself that I'll be able to do the the
challenge of Roman 365. I just didn't
know how much we would make and as it's
turned out we've ticked both boxes with
regards to
36 500 million pounds
amazing amazing achievement Gary listen
enjoy the New Year's Eve happy New Year
to you and your family and have a good
beer
thank you very much thank you